si quelque chose et se frappe
plaque de métal puis ça coince
bande transporteuse, c'est-à-dire généralement
gilet pare-balles militaire original ici
une couche de Kevlar est placée, mais comme il
très cher mais pas probablement dans notre
situations
il est très difficile de l'avoir à l'usage
tapis roulant
qu'elle a signé
livré à moitié oui et
chaque api ext shooter pose son bataillon
bien sur notre poisson chat vivant clap à tout le monde
vis ma vie des tigres en bonne santé bro palam
gâteaux au fromage
sera
Mais
assurément très important parce que je
Je comprends ce qui m'attend
responsabilité et pas seulement pour la santé
les gens, mais pour la vie des gens et
à chaque fois c'est beaucoup de nerfs
consacré à la fabrication et
essai